Okay, first thing is going to be boring as. All right. Okay.
I don't know why. I do know why Willie Mac decides to run and
make a video like 2 hours after DMing me now. I understand. I
get it. Okay. We have to do the Destiny bad because we're it's
too much heat from other people, which listen, I get it's a lot
of heat online. Okay, that's fine. I get it.
I understand it. And Ethan obviously with this whole um I noticed
all the comments on the video where people were like uh where
people were like um wow I noticed that the crew was like very
giddy and excited and happy this episode when it seems like they're
usually very sullen and they don't say anything cuz anytime Ethan
is criticizing his son all of them are in the in the sunken place
behind their behind their desks. Uh, but when it was me, oh,
they're so excited to repost or retweet or retread whatever whatever
stuff pops up online.
Um,
so the thing is, so you know what? Actually, this guy said it
best. Hold on. Wait. Can't defend yourself. Answer here. I'm
trying to meet your request of giving non-stop defense because
your baby ass can't defend yourself. Keemstar will make insane
accusations, crownless accusations, and then he expects you to
defend yourself. In fact, he likes it if he'll come on your his
show and defend himself. That's how his operation works. And
so he go, "Oh, well, he didn't say anything in his defense, so
he must be guilty." Have you ever lied to anyone on YouTube?
Who are you theing FBI? I don't >> I'm not going to play
this game of every single time some insane person releases some
random
or piece of paper, whatever, that I'm going to come and run through
all these communities and try to give some crazy explanation
for whatever else. Because one, the only thing that's happening
is I see that every single thing I possibly say gets either misconstrued
or drawn out to the most absurd reality possible to where Nicholas
Oreo cakes or whatever is saying that I'm threatening Willy's
wife because I said she was a MSAD agent, which case I have to
clarify was a joke. Okay, I was indeed joking. I'm sorry for
that joke. To the best of my knowledge, okay, can't say 100%.
To the best of my knowledge, Willy's wife is not a massage agent.
Okay, number one. And number two, it feeds the content network
for all of these people who just make content out of all by responses
basically no matter what I say. Okay. I was hoping that I I guess
Ethan wouldn't have a wouldn't have his his uh destiny. I know
that he's like been hungry to like kind of show some disavowel
of me because every time him and Hassan fight, Hassan like uses
me as some attack vector to go after Ethan, which is weird because
I mean at least it should be proven today. I have traded a total
of two messages with Ethan in my entire life. I've said this
before. I think it was like I don't even know when. It was after
October 7th when um Hassan's chat was like spamming insane and
I went over on stream and I think Ethan DM'd me and he asked
me he was like, "Wait, where did you get the chat message from?"
And I told him I think this might be 2 years ago. Yeah, these
are so but I think Ethan is like so desperate to get away from
the just controls me narrative that he decides to do his little
unhingeable [__] stream. Yeah, I'm going back to
the where I was before, which is I'll wait until my court case
is over. Uh, I'll go over filings as they come out, but this
I I realized that Well, I didn't know that Willie would make
a video with him crying into the camera of like, "Oh, this is
911. Record record." Um,
I can talk about more of this when my case is over. Uh, which
is hopefully soon, but who knows? Whenever whenever stuff gets
read. Um,
oh, now we've moved to the whatever, like 17, 18. Here's the
thing, okay? When it comes to ages for hooking up with people
in general, like I feel like you can play this game like regardless
of how far you want to go, 18 and older is an adult in the United
States. If people are like, "Oh, you should wait until they're
21." Then I feel like it would just move to 21 and older. Like,
oh, why are you hooking with a 21-year-old or why you hang with
a 23-y old? Like, listen, you're an adult. you're an adult. I
don't know what the point is of moving the bar on this. If you
think that like 18 years old is like a horrible age of people
to hook up, then maybe we can make like tax brackets for for
hookup consent. But I don't know. Like it's just funny to see
the bar moving this. I don't care. Whatever. Listen, I'll say
what I said before, okay? Whatever you've read about me online
or whatever you want to post about me, it's true and worse. Okay?
All of it is true and worse. Okay? The feds are coming. The cases
are mounting.
The
MSAD and the KGB are tracking. Okay, they will be here one day.
I've been streaming for 16 years, but this is the last one. Okay,
the walls are closing in this time. For real, for real, for real.
Okay, they're closing in. I swear to God, they are. All right.
I've never been more on edge and afraid of the walls closing
in as I am right now. Okay. Seems like you have an actual case
of defamation from Ethan. No, maybe. Maybe not. The thing is,
lawsuits suck. They're expensive. It's annoying. Um, I don't
even know it's worth it. Uh, and I just don't care that much
cuz you know what? We just keep on rolling. Okay. Bro, I can't
believe how quick these two are to believe anything they read
on Kiwi Farms and they've been harassing them for the last few
months. You know what? That's how it goes. Okay. I just don't
know why you talked to Willie Mac at all. Um, I don't remember.
I think he messaged me on something, but I I mean, I'd been in
communication with him. I just didn't expect them to run and
make a YouTube video in 2 seconds based off some DMs with us.
Obviously, the I would have approached that conversation with
a lot more care in terms of how I'm phrasing things, obviously.
But you know what? Whatever. Listen, what again, whatever you
want to believe, believe what you want. Okay, the feds, they're
on their way. All right, I'm just trying to trying to stream
before they get here. Inshallah, ABH3. Oh, I'm so glad he finally
found his voice. I wonder how awkward it feels when his boss
is sitting there railing on his Turkish idol and he has to sit
there and hold his tongue the entire time. knowing that he's
getting by Hassan's entire fan base the entire time regardless
and that being a spineless cook actually isn't helping him at
any part of this whatsoever. But that's okay. And Ethan has to
feel bad too cuz he's sitting there while his whole crew is awkwardly
staring at him because nobody wants to participate. It's all
good. H3 has been a girly pop gossipy channel for a while now.
His audience is likely majority women who watch things like RuPaul
and talk pop culture celebrity relationships. It was inevitable.
Um I actually disagree. I feel like the H fan base for the most
part is actually one of the more chiller fan bases on the internet.
I think it's because not to not to pull my uh W card out, but
I think it's because it's like probably a little bit more women
versus men. Like it wouldn't surprise me if that fan base was
like 40% women. Um
but then also because they do kind of like more pop cultury stuff,
it does get a bit more grounded. Like I see a lot of comments
popping up um even in that H3 subreddit about how like all politics
streamers are cancer and all of those communities are cancer
and that's about like 95% correct. It is a special type of cancer.
Um although again I like I would blame I would point my fingers
to Hassan and for that um and AB and all the little um people
that are hiding behind the desks that are too afraid to say anything
in those segments. I would say that those people are like you
can point fingers directly at those kinds of people to blame.
I think it would be way more interesting and more fascinating
to have policy oriented debates. Um, if somebody disagrees on
Israel Palestine, you know, we can fight over the massacres,
you know, in other places pre48, you know, justify or pre-40
justify all the back and forth fighting and who right or wrong.
Like, I think those would be super interesting and fascinating
discussions to have, but nobody wants to have those conversations.
They just want to call everybody up or whatever the [__]
else. Hold on. Wait, I just had another random fan snap me. Uh,
nude, check this out. I'm showing it to all my friends right
now. How old is she? Oh, I have no idea. But oh, check this one
out, too. And this one out, too. And this one out, too. Um, but
yeah, I think um, listen, if that's what people want online politics
to be, then that's what I guess that's what online politics could
be. It is what it is. Tell everyone you make more than them.
Pretty sure Ethan makes more than me. Those guys are loaded.
A Olivia and Dan are cockus on agents that never defend Ethan
when they beef. It's insane.
Yeah, but I mean, like, it's also by design, too. Um, oh god,
I'm trying. I don't want to give them charity. It's by design,
too, because anytime these people step out and criticize Assan,
that entire network of people is also going to come out and harass
all of those people as well, right? So, AB, Olivia, all those
people, if they don't tow the lefty line, you know, they're going
to come under huge fire from that side as well. So, they kind
of have to because if you don't tow the line on their side, then
they're going to get called token figures or um you know, Uncle
Tom's or
um whatever else. So, I mean like they're I mean to be fair,
they're in a rough they're in a rough position as well. So, but
I mean like it's it's whatever. That's okay. Take a deep breath.
Fortress fortress arc away. Not really. I feel like I need to
play a like a one month video game break maybe. I still think
the I still think the Ryan Beard memes were probably my favorite.
um the making the video on me who has the scariest and most dangerous
community on the internet and then announcing that he's making
a video on Hassan Ethan and that he's going to be fair and the
lefties bully him so hard he has to stop he can't even he can't
even finish his research for the video I think that was funny
how is it that after every drama/c scandal involving you is over
and settled down you seem to somehow get right back into it cuz
I cuz like 95% of it is um and I don't know just it is what it
is and I have a penchant for dealing with crazies online, I guess.
Although, this might be the one. This is This is it. Have you
sworn off friendships with content creators? Yeah, kind of. I
like I'll say this again. I And I don't think I this message
can't carry. The thing that's the most annoying I think about
all of this is that she was actually 12. No, I'm just kidding.
The thing that's the most annoying about all of this is that
um I think a lot of people and I keep seeing these comments pop
up on my own subreddit. I might have permaned you for this. Also,
by the way, if I perman email the mods and I'll they'll unban
you. Okay. The most annoying thing is like people keep thinking
that all of this drama keeps popping up like every month, every
six months, like over and over and over again. And it's but it's
not. It's the same story that gets rehashed or refiltered in
a slightly different way from the revenge leaks at the end of
2024. Like it's the same story over and over again with a new
twist or a new thing or a new added, whatever. But people have
this perception that there's like a crazy thing happening like
every few months. But it's not a crazy thing happening every
few months. It's just a stupid from this person I talked to back
in 2022, 2023, 2020. Yeah, it's just annoying. Can you respond
to Willy's reply because to be honest, your defense is not convincing.
Good. I hope it's not, but the reality is is literally every
single thing I've said has gotten twisted and has gotten morphed
or moved to like the most ridiculous [__] in the
universe. So, I'm going to shut the [__] up and not
talk about this till my court case is over. Okay? Because I'm
binded bound bounded binded. I'm I'm restricted like 15 different
ways from saying stupid such that in talking about um a hearing
that I had with uh Pixie like their lawyers already like I think
two days ago like moved to file a motion was like we are trying
to get this thing sealed and he's still talking about the transcript.
So like no it's not worth it cuz none of it is obviously doing
me any favors anyway. So
uh yeah this is not an argument that I'm going to win at the
moment publicly which is fine but just have to wait until wait
until my case is over. Recently heard you say you used to play
Eve Online. Any chance we get some casual EVE gameplay or are
you done with it for good? Uh, Eve gameplay. Well, actually,
I shouldn't say anything cuz I haven't played the game in maybe
a decade. Is sitting on a gate or on a POS for 6 hours praying
to God that the enemy fleet warps in so you guys can actually
do something and praying to God you don't get wiped by stealth
bombers or something first or there's a really cringy drop that
nukes your whole fleet because you weren't ready for ships to
come or whatever. But I'm genuinely asking this is
how is it that you don't break down when it seems you have friends
moving around every few weeks. I've been watching you for 3 years.
I'm man and it seems you have friend changes every few weeks
and everyone turns to you every so often. Except Dan, I understand
the online world is a wild place but I believe that that the
what the average person thinks you is important. I think about
how you maneuver in life. That makes sense. My baseline I've
said this a lot. I don't think people believe me when I say this.
Generally, if somebody has a hard time understanding me or if
somebody thinks there's something that is just doesn't make sense
usually cuz people don't take what I say at face value, which
is fine. I don't care. Um, that's because I'm a secret manipulator/
mentalist slash whatever else. My expectation for people online
is already as low as it possibly can be. Like it's kind of every
online friendship there's just like a fuse attached to it. I
just don't know what the timer is on the fuse. That's just how
I approach it. So, it is what it is. Although to be fair for
the Ethan stuff, we didn't even have a bridge or relationship.
So what are you going to do? You probably know, but the snark
post that Willie was reading off is almost verbatim. The KF post
that doc is a girl. Yeah, I'm aware. Same thing with um with
a son on stream just reading down
um Blav, which is You know what? Hey, listen. I see you. I see
the way you move. Okay. Plus one. Wow. Traxx, thanks for the
gifted subs, buddy. Hi, Destiny. Your issue is that politics
is so virtue heavy that if you do things like hook up with people
over a decade younger, you'll get attacked. Shouldn't you adjust
a bit in that regard? Um, so I'll say the same thing. I think
I already said at the beginning of the stream, but I'll say over
and over again. Um, all of this drama is drug up from old conversations.
It's the same thing getting recycled over and over and over again.
That's like nothing. None of this is from 2024. None of this
is from 2025.
Um,
like it's all just old recycled.
Uh, also I'm not running for office, so it's not like I'm trying
to be a politician or some. And um, also Trump is president.
This guy's civily liable for was banging prostitutes while his
wife was at home taking care of the newborn. Also, RPGs like
Path of Exile or Diablo 23 4. They are the perfect background
game. Um, the thing is is that ever since I started my Vancing
stuff, I don't have as much of an interest in like playing a
game while chatting with people are doing things because usually
I can focus on the conversation a bit better. Um, like if I was
going to play a game, I think I would just play a game, which
I might. Maybe I'll do that soon. Wow. For Moroni,
thanks for [__] I don't Oh, 20 sub, buddy. Just curious,
do you do therapy or do you have some system that helps cope
with this or you're just built different? I am built different
and I do do therapy with myself. Okay. Okay. Then also I said,
um, okay, this is my last response to any of this and then I'm
done. Okay. I'm not talking about any of this cuz literally none
of this is none of this helping me publicly. So there's literally
no point in doing this. Die said he can't respond to the laughter
score case with Pixie. Fair enough if true. I think you should
probably get on stream with his legal counsel and have them explain
why having alleged CB since November is okay in this instance
and legal. I've not seen one lawyer agree with this for I don't
know how you have to be to think that one that any lawyer would
ever agree to do this. The whole point like why would your lawyer
ever counsel you in a public setting in a public forum? Part
of the whole like benefit of patient client confidentiality or
um not patient uh lawyer uh client confidentiality is that these
conversations aren't accessible to public. So the idea that any
law firm would agree, oh hey, let's do some legal counseling
in a public setting is beyond stupid. Number one, number two,
the to assume that I'm not like in contact with anybody or having
conversations about things that are going on is also beyond.
Um but it's not. But it's not it's not it's not it's not it's
not sorry hold on I keep over with this okay this is not it's
not okay this is intentional I understand like I said before
I understand that people catch a lot of heat when they are associated
with me and so sometimes you have to do the performative like
oh my god like is OBS recording I I got a report like I get it
okay but don't pretend that you're like after some actual information
or actually because if anybody gave a [__] about
any of that at all there would be a lot more questions for other
people involved but listen I get it Okay.
Okay, that's really it. I'm not not feeding this not feeding
this machine. Um, Eddie Logger, we will chat more once my case
ends, which is either in 1 month, 6 months, or 1 year. I guess
whatever. No. Does Olivia uh have any political opinions? She
seems culturally socialist, but I would sort of say the same
thing about someone even Ledwig or even Atriarch. I think most
of his non I have no idea. I don't know the political positions
of anybody on the HV show. I just know that they were all of
them are in an awkward position because obviously they did leftovers
of the son for a while. A lot of them are very um I'm trying
to think of a nicer word than like beholden or captured by cuz
that makes them sound like they're children. But like there obviously
there's a lot of um audience pressure. Not even from the H3 audience
though, but from other people uh related to the staff. So, they're
in weird spots. But is there no limit how much they can keep
dragging it with motions? Um I have no clue. Well, no. I guess
there's not really. I think at some point you can push for what,
like a rule 12 thing or something. Um but the I mean it's you're
right in civil court you can spam the the docket as much as you
want. I had a crazy woman etock me last year and I turned my
life into a mini nightmare. It's not from one of those girl groups
like the app T. It was total BS. But when men are being accused
of anything by women, the burden to defend yourself, keep in
mind, I'm not even being accused of anything by a woman at all
right now. Right. This might be the first Well, actually, I don't
know. This is the first time that somebody's tried to cancel
somebody for somebody's alleged age when the victim isn't even
making any of the
It's just other third parties. Jesus. Um I don't know. Um, I
don't agree with all your BS, but you're not some beacon of morality
for me or anything. These people judging you nontop are living
rally where they find the purpose they desperately missing. Um,
maybe I don't know. I like I wouldn't even care. Listen, you
want to judge me for whatever that's fine, but it's just like
the idea that um the idea that like I'm some like seeker of like
the whole Anna drama was probably some of the most infamous woman
drama I stream and she's like my age. So, what are you going
to do? One must imagine Destiny happy. True. I love pushing the
boulder up the hill. What the [__] I don't know anything
about this man, but he once decided he wanted to debate me and
I was harassed by his fans for months while I said, "Who is that?
What is happening? Who is this? Did we harass this person for
months? Did I miss the email on that guys on the brigader on
the brigade list?" Rob, thanks for subscri
Listen, bro. I'm on a first name basis, okay? With multiple field
officers here. They come to my house all the time. I basically
just have the reason why my stream is late on Fridays is because
I have like my Friday afternoon coffee, okay, with my local FBI
field office agents where they go through the where they go through
the weekly reports on me. I'm like, "Did you really want to kill
this guy?" It's like, "No, that was a meme." It's like, "Okay,
why is Dan backing off?" Because people are spam calling his
wife's workplace and harassing his family. Yeah. But hey, listen.
Good times. But that's okay. We take a deep breath.
Ew. Oh, no. Do you think audiences like H3s are more toxic? Do
female heavy audiences have more of a propensity to be No. I
like I've said a million times, I don't I think the H3's audience
is like significantly more normal than any audience over here
in the political streaming world. Just at least based on the
little bit that I've said. I think for I'm really far outside
of my comfort zone, okay? Cuz I don't dabble in these communities
too much, but from like I don't even want to associate them with
like fem stuff, but like if if you go to like female heavy audiences,
and that doesn't mean just female heavy audiences. So like H3s
might might